こんな反射者なぜこうなんか値段と最近俺もダメなのかな
脳がこうなんか降ってきてる気がするんですよだって僕今僕の守備を言うとしたら
友情カードベイブレード
やばくないですかも25歳だよ
って思いながら別にいいやと思ってます外れ雪よねそれがおもちゃ屋さんに行くと
こんなものを見つけました
るーるーん
これは一体なんでしょこれなんだメカパッドいいねーなーのずビックキューブのつまり
床に置いてあったんでなんかルービックキューブの友達からと思って買ってみたんです
けどもネットそうじゃないみたいでございますミラー9分
いろんな形や目で弾バレちゃうんじゃないか外れんでしたミラーけどいろんな形に変形
しますこれで円形するってもえーだっていい資格じゃなきゃ
は子はなにこれヤなんかすげーリーダーすっごい綺麗ってか普通に家に飾っておきて
レベル必要なルービックキューブだったらこれでこう聞け
あ動いてそのリンピックゲームだったらこの縦と横の回転しかできないんですけどもう
見るからにねどういうわけではなさそうなんですよね
動かしていますもう釣りこれいいのう待って
普通のこれも普通のルービックキューブの動きが出てますね
グーッと待って待って
ダイワハウスで前すごい形が指つ2月ホレこういうやつなのかな
ペーパーところ取り戻せる俺自分をもうダメかもしれんすげーすげー
パッドリストの急なんですけどここだけ損でってちゃって何これ形がちょっと変わっ
てっちゃうこれどうすればいいの元に戻せば成功どうでしょうか
となると僕がた分も取り返しのつかないところまでしてしまっています
ていた
ん
[音楽]
助けてこれを上じゃんと言ってこんなことせっていうんだよったけんじゃねーよもう
なんか動作を行いことになってきてしまいましたまずどうすればいいのこれは何かでも
ルービックキューブと同じ用途なんですよねたぶん
ベビー9ゲームは移動添えるんですけどもこれも形は揃えるとはそれを形は揃えると
いうか多分頑張れば元せるのではないでしょうか
これやばいなでも複雑すぎて俺の角
がて一生かかってもできないかもしれないぐらいのヤバさを感じるな
ふぅ
焼けるたぶんきっとアレなんだと思いますビックキューブの種類の風ですどっちが
難しいかわかんですけど
[音楽]
ん
[拍手]
あーおれムズイ所だったこんなにさあ作ることありますよねこれ崩したら俺だって追わ
れたぜ多分
やっても遅いですね形変わるテープ驚きますので普通こういう私ならないですもん
[音楽]
a でもギヤーはだなんとか再生できそうなんですけど再生してるの
me
バッハ